اذا مشاهدينا هذا نوريال روبيني خبيرا
اقتصادي يتنبا بالازمه الاقتصاديه
العالميه عام 2008 ويتنبا اليوم بسيناريو
مشابه بلواسو اما هذا الشخص فهو سان باك
مان صوره تسيدت العناوين والظهوره يمثل
رعبا اقتصاديا من ازمه في سوق العملات
الرقميه قد تمتدوا الى القطاع المصرفي
التقليدي تماما كما حصل ما بين كلمن
براذرز في بدايه ازمه 2008 القصه
شركه اف تي اكس احد رموز اتداول الرقمي
وسام بانكمان هو مديرها العام الشركه
اعلنت افلاسها مليارات الدولارات تبخرت
وباتمان باتا بحكم الواقع ملياردير
المفلسا لكن كيف اصبح بنك مان ملياردير
اصلا قصته القصيره للغايه نحن في عام 2017
القيود التي كانت تضعها البنوك اضافه الى
الطلب المرتفع على البيتكوين جعل
اليابانيين ان ينتظرون لاسابيع قبل الحصول
على العملات الرقميه والنتيجه ارتفاع
ثمنها بالنسبه 10% مقارنه بالاسعار
الامريكيه وهنا
ظهر بنك مان اسس شركه الميدان للابحاث
شركه بوظيفه واحده هي استغلال تفاوت
الاسعار بين اليابان وامريكا لتحقق هذه
الشركه الناشئه ارباح تصل الى 20 مليون
دولار في اليوم
لا تشرين ثم اسس افتي اكس التي التاهمت
حصص المنافسين الاقدم في سوق التداول
العملات الرقميه وبالتوازي تحول سامبا الى
اغنى شاب في العالم
لثروه بلغت شهر مارس الماضي 26 مليارا
و500 مليون دولار